[Música]
si lo miramos con cierta perspectiva
América Latina es una especie de péndulo
ideológico entre Polos opuestos desde la
dictadura militares de los 70 y los 80
pasando por la transición a la
democracia la lluvia de privatizaciones
y la liberalización económica de los 90
o el estatismo todopoderoso del conocido
como socialismo del siglo XXI casi que
podríamos decir que en América Latina
todo es o blanco o negro y el asalto de
Los partidarios de bolsonaro al congreso
a la Corte Suprema y al palacio de plan
alto sede de la presidencia brasileña
han sido solo el último ejemplo de esta
especie de Furia apasional que
frecuentemente tan difícil resulta de
hacer compatible con la democracia una
Furia además que siempre siempre está
dominada por ciertos parámetros comunes
que creo todos conocemos perfectamente
Pero y si en cierta forma y a pesar de
los recientes acontecimientos este
péndulo estuviera realmente
resquebrajándose puede estar América
Latina ante un punto de inflexión
ideológica arranquemos
[Aplausos]
Por cierto hablando de puntos de
inflexión la Guerra de Ucrania ha
cambiado por completo las tornas se han
invertido ahora es el ejército ucraniano
quien lleva la iniciativa en el campo de
batalla mientras las fuerzas rusas no
paran de sumar nuevos fracasos sin
embargo el frente militar no es el único
campo de batalla en este caso la guerra
económica también juega un papel
fundamental es especialmente para la
capacidad de resistencia de Ucrania Así
que la pregunta que tenemos que hacernos
es cómo está evolucionando esta guerra
económica si quieres saberlo No te
pierdas el último vídeo de si lo hubiera
sabido y el canal de información
financiera de mutativos con el que
participamos donde te cuentan todos los
detalles os dejo el enlace en la
descripción dicho esto Ahora sí
Comencemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
los primeros 10 años del siglo XXI
sumergieron de lleno a prácticamente
toda la región en lo que diferentes
analistas políticos calificaron como la
marea Roja en marzo de 2005 por ejemplo
se estimaba que el 75% de los 350
millones de habitantes de América Latina
estaban gobernados por partidos de
izquierdas en aquella época podemos
recordar a líderes como Chávez Daniel
Ortega Lula da Silva Rafael Correa Evo
Morales o la familia kirchner haciendo
numerosas reformas económicas y sociales
para acercarse al socialismo y nutrir al
estado con cada vez más y más
instrumentos intervencionistas y ojo que
no solo hablo del terreno económico lo
dedicará casi Managua ya sabemos que fue
mucho más allá de las cuentas públicas
desde Ecuador decía Bolívar o nos unimos
de verdad o un nuevo coloniaje le
llegaremos a la posteridad el banco del
Sur La telesur
una televisora del sur Una petrosur la
unidad energética del sur y eso por no
hablar del propio salto a la democracia
en aquella vorágine de entusiasmo
socialista se generaron plataformas
multilaterales como la unión de Naciones
suramericanas unasur la comunidad de
Estados latinoamericanos y caribeños
celac o la alianza bolivariana para los
pueblos de nuestra América el alba vamos
que el proceso parecía del todo
imparable pero un momento porque sin
embargo la corrupción y el voto popular
al menos allí donde se respetó Claro
está comenzaron a romper una por una las
olas de toda esa inmensa marea roja
fijaos 24 de noviembre de 2015 macri
gana en Argentina y pone final
kirchnerismo tras 12 años 7 de diciembre
de 2015 la oposición venezolana obtiene
mayor número de escaños y controlará la
asamblea nacional 31 de agosto de 2016
en pitchment Dilma Rousseff es
destituida como presidenta de Brasil 5
de febrero de 2018 Lenin Moreno bloquea
Rafael Correa Ecuador vota en referéndum
a favor de limitar a dos periodos el
mandato presidencial 28 de octubre de
2018 bolsonaro selecto presidente de
Brasil ya lo veis el giro que la región
pegó desde el año genera un escenario
totalmente contrario a la marea roja
cuyas fuerzas quedaron muy debilitadas
Aunque eso sí no derrotadas la victoria
de López Obrador en México seguida de la
derrota de Mauricio macri en 2019 a la
par de las revueltas sociales en chile y
el regreso del partido de Evo Morales al
poder en Bolivia en el año 2020
volvieron a patear el tablero político
latinoamericano otra vez Pero ahora bien
fue esta sucesión de los hechos una
especie de remake de la marea roja Pues
bien veámoslo
[Música]
del recambio político
queridos amigos amigas cuando en julio
de 2018 el 53,19% de los mexicanos
llevaron a Andrés Manuel López Obrador
amlo a la presidencia no solo rompieron
con la hegemonía del pri en el país la
cual apenas había sido brevemente
erosionada por el pan sino que vieron la
primera campanada del cambio que se
avecinaba Y es que a pesar de que amlo
tuvo que convivir como una especie de
Lobo solitario con presidentes
disidentes al socialismo como Piñera en
Chile bolso en Brasil Duque en Colombia
o máquina Argentina y el estallido
social en chile y Ecuador en 2019
terminaron por abrir de nuevo en la caja
de Pandora en la región
a todos los chilenos Ellos están en
guerra contra todos los chilenos de
buena voluntad que queremos vivir en
democracia con libertad y en paz
La ola de disturbios en Santiago que
terminó provocando Incluso el inicio de
un proceso Constituyente fue
posiblemente un shock tremendamente
traumático para los países contrarios a
la marea roja hasta ese momento el
modelo chileno había servido como un
ejemplo de estabilidad y crecimiento
gracias a sus políticas más orientadas
al mercado sin embargo tras los
disturbios esa idea ese modelo empezó a
dejar de ser un objetivo para
convertirse en un mito con un alto coste
político
Claro si ese era el resultado quién iba
a querer replicar el modelo
y sabéis que fue justo Entonces cuando
desde Caracas los melancólicos custodios
del conocido como socialismo del siglo
XXI comenzaron a vaticinar un huracán
ideológico que volvería a posicionar
otra vez a la izquierda en lo más alto
del poder político está soplando a una
Brisa bolivariana
está soplando una Brisa bolivariana
que va a venir desde el Río Grande y un
poquito más arriba hasta la Patagonia
Brisa bolivariana Brisa de los pueblos
libertarios sin embargo lo cierto Es que
estaba en la historia fue muy diferente
al menos muy diferente de lo que los
maduros cabellos y Compañía tenían en
mente aquellos estallidos de violencia
no hicieron que la sociedad reclamase el
regreso de los referentes y los
custodios de la marea roja sino que en
cambio generaron resultados un tanto
aguados ni para unos ni para otros
atentos
un rojo que destiñe
Si vemos la tendencia de los gobiernos
más destacados de América Latina en el
año 2019 podemos constatar que la
izquierda había sido diezmada del mapa
político de la región salvo por algunos
casos concretos como México Nicaragua
Cuba o Venezuela
sin embargo unos tres años después la
brisa bolivariana parece haber hecho su
trabajo con cambiazos tan llamativos
como los que se han dado Incluso en
bastiones del centro derecha
latinoamericano como Colombia
sí tenemos en cuenta el mapa no sé
parece bastante claro podemos decir que
la manera roja está de vuelta el
socialismo del siglo XXI se ha hecho de
nuevo con el poder otra vez la
revolución bolivariana vuelve a marcar
la música a seguir verdad pues lo cierto
Es que no
sí a ver los partidos de izquierdas y en
ocasiones partidos y movimientos muy
vinculados a la vieja Guardia
bolivariana se han hecho de nuevo con el
poder sin embargo lo cierto es que el
perfil de los actuales líderes parece
muy distante de lo que en su día
hubieran defendido Los Chávez Castro
Ortega y compañía no me creéis Pues
fijaos fijaos por 104 votos a favor 18
en contra y 24 abstenciones la cámara
aprobó una resolución promovida por
representantes de la udi que respalda
las declaraciones del presidente Gabriel
borich respecto de los regímenes
dictatoriales de Venezuela Nicaragua y
Cuba de que yo soy
este pues que es una calumnia eso sí
digamos hizo una promesa su sociedad
digamos una distribución social de la
renta petrolera Que es de lo que viven
los venezolanos
el pueblo votó por él varias veces pero
la promesa quedó incumplida
en qué sentido en que realmente no se
puede construir una equidad social una
justicia social
en una economía que solo extrae petróleo
28 de enero de 2022 con apoyo argentino
la ONU vuelve a condenar al régimen de
maduro en Venezuela es decir la región
giró a la izquierda eso es innegable
sin embargo esa izquierda aparece algo
diferente a la que protagonizó el
comienzo del siglo no parece ni de lejos
esa izquierda Revolucionaria que estaba
enamorada de los largos discursos de
Hugo Chávez los nuevos gobiernos
encarnan algo así como una especie de
socialismo latinoamericano diluido
quizás incluso una especie de
socialdemocracia Latina y qué queréis
que os diga nos pueden gustar más o nos
pueden gustar menos estas corrientes
políticas pero no creo que haya muchas
dudas respecto a que parecen mucho mejor
en todos los aspectos que los
movimientos revolucionarios de principio
de siglo
por lo general los nuevos gobiernos no
hablan de revoluciones expropiaciones
nacionalizaciones ni cosas por el estilo
Y eso pues parece un avance porque la
larga puede generar mucha más
estabilidad insisto incluso Aunque no
nos gusten sus políticas el cambio de
cromos ha llevado una América Latina
política mucho menos radical incluso
Lula ha ganado las elecciones en Brasil
con un ticket electoral que tiene como
compañero de Fórmula a Gerardo alquim un
referente del centro derecha brasileño y
un antiguo contrincante electoral del
propio Lula quizás de alguna forma Petro
siga siendo en parte la única excepción
parece sentirse demasiado cómodo con
tirarnos como maduro pero Incluso en
Colombia la realidad política bajo Petro
no tiene nada que ver con lo que fueron
la mayoría de los movimientos de
izquierda latinoamericanos durante el
comienzo del siglo XXI y la pregunta es
a qué se debe de repentino cambio es una
cuestión generacional es fruto de la
autocrítica de la izquierda
latinoamericana es no sé por querer
emular a los países europeos pues quizás
probablemente sea un poco de todo Claro
que hay otro factor que puede haber
contribuido a esta pérdida de influencia
y estoy hablando del factor financiero
Sí sí me habéis escuchado bien atentos
[Música]
ya no hay quien pague la fiesta
queridos amigos amigas la marea Roja de
principios de siglo tenía un epicentro
Caracas desde la capital venezolana Hugo
Chávez Se posicionaba como un referente
político pero también financiero
especialmente para todos los Aventureros
de la época fijaos 4 de enero de 2006
Evo Morales se suma al proyecto
antineoliberal y antiimperialista de
Chávez en su visita Venezuela uno de los
convenios firmados serán los 30 millones
de dólares que Chávez se ha comprometido
a entregar a Bolivia para obras sociales
además de suministrar todo el
combustible que consume Bolivia 17 de
febrero de 2006 Venezuela Disfruta de su
Bonanza petrolera los expertos creen que
el presidente Chávez ha gastado unos
5.000 millones de dólares en empresas
energéticas fuera de Venezuela incluida
refinerías de petróleo nuevas o de
operación conjunta en Cuba Uruguay y
Brasil 22 de noviembre de 2007 Venezuela
sigue acaparando deuda Argentina
29 de septiembre de 2009 Ecuador acepta
La donación de seis cazas de Venezuela
que 16 de abril de 2008 Venezuela
oficializa acuerdos de suministro crudo
a Bolivia y Nicaragua Venezuela
oficializó tres acuerdos de suministro
directo de crudo por un total de 1,48
millones de barriles mensuales a Bolivia
Nicaragua y Haití en condiciones
especiales de pago que incluyen
intereses del 2% anual ya lo veis la
tarjeta de crédito hacia pagos por aquí
por allá como si no hubiera mañana y por
supuesto también financiaba a todo tipo
de movimientos políticos muy
radicalizados de izquierdas todo esto
contribuyó a reunir a un púlpito de
gobiernos alrededor de aquel utópico
proyecto de la patria grande o mejor
dicho la chequera grande
pero si todo esto ocurría de manera
oficial por debajo de la mesa se estima
que la asistencia del chavismo a sus
aliados era más compleja y el caso más
emblemático sería el de Anthony Wilson
quien reconoció tras ser capturado en
Buenos Aires llevar cerca de 800 mil
dólares de pedevesa para financiar la
campaña de Cristina kirchner en 2007
fijaos era el dinero otra vez le
preguntó el dinero de Venezuela y hacia
dónde iba el dinero el dinero iba para
la campaña presidencial de la actual
presidente Cristina de kirchner Y es que
claro si la fiesta era gratis por qué no
sumarse eso es lo que debieron de pensar
muchos líderes políticos de primera
segunda y tercera fila de la región
líderes políticos que ahora se han
cambiado de chaqueta Además está claro
que los que cogían el dinero e invitaban
a las copas eran los más populares de la
clase sin embargo y las cosas son
completamente distintas
[Música]
la Venezuela de hoy está prácticamente
quebrada sin posibilidades de respaldar
económicamente ningún proyecto político
relevante el descalabro de las cuentas
públicas producto de la compulsiva
nacionalización de las Industrias
privadas y la falta de inversión en
materia de infraestructura petrolera ha
hecho que Venezuela no sea capaz
siquiera de extraer su propio petróleo Y
eso hablando de un país que tiene las
mayores reservas de crudo convencional
del mundo es de suspenso mayúsculo
y eso era en 2019 porque en 2022 apenas
pudieron producir unos 700.000 barriles
diarios claro cuando tienes las
alcalinas te puedes dar todo tipo de
caprichos pero cuando están vacías esa
ya es otra historia pero sigamos
una izquierda cada vez más limitada
Si volvemos al mapa político de 2022 Es
evidente que las corrientes electorales
han cambiado hacia la izquierda pero
como ya hemos dicho los referentes que
han llegado al poder son algo distintos
al menos han cambiado respecto a lo que
era la norma habitual en la primera
década del siglo XXI ahora mantienen
discursos más moderados y no dudan
enarbolar la bandera de la tercera vía
lo que insisto no quiere decir que su
proyecto político tenga que resultarnos
atractivos eso ya dependerá de cada cual
y además las sociedades también parecen
más críticas ahí tenemos por ejemplo la
derrota del referéndum sobre la nueva
constitución en Chile la victoria de las
reformas de la calle Uruguay o el cambio
de signo político que parece que se
avecina en Argentina los nuevos líderes
de izquierdas o centro de izquierda no
solo no están viviendo una luna de miel
sino que en muchos casos están perdiendo
Muchas de sus grandes batallas políticas
y eso a pesar de haberse moderado por el
camino y por todo esto decimos que el
histórico péndulo de la política
latinoamericana puede haberse roto Claro
que quizás pensar latinoamérica en una
función izquierda derecha pueda ser algo
anticuado en los últimos años la región
parece haberse aproximado a una dinámica
más de tipo populismo antipopulismo ante
el fracaso de los personalismos de
Cristina Fernández kirchner Evo Morales
o Rafael correa
sea como sea es que de esta forma es por
lo que quizás la ola haya dejado de ser
estrictamente rosa para ser algo más
rosada y en cualquier caso este 2023
viene con una agenda más que movida para
reconocer Cuál será el nuevo péndulo
político que marcará el ritmo en la
región Guillermo lasso enfrentará un
referéndum en febrero donde someterán
los Pilares de su programa de gobierno
al voto popular buscando al estilo de la
calle Pou empoderar su gestión el resto
del mandato por su parte Guatemala
Paraguay Argentina tendrán que renovar
sus ejecutivos mientras que Petro tendrá
las elecciones regionales de octubre su
primer teselectoral como presidente
luego la feroz lucha interna del
oficialismo en Bolivia y la crisis
institucional de Perú siembra de
interrogantes El Porvenir de dichas
naciones Mientras que el desarrollo del
gobierno de Lula en Brasil será clave
para entender Hacia dónde demonios se
mueve la izquierda latinoamericana será
esta cada vez más Rosa te guste más o te
guste menos este tipo de movimientos
creo que la inmensa mayoría podemos
coincidir que sería una buena noticia
sobre todo si tenemos en cuenta el
historial de esta región Claro que con
América Latina nunca se sabe pero o sea
como se ha llegado hasta aquí turno para
ti qué piensas sobre la ola Rosa que
actualmente tiñe la región crees que del
socialismo del siglo XXI ya quedó
descartado o puede resurgir está a la
izquierda latinoamericana renovándose o
solo Guarda las apariencias dejadnos por
aquí abajo vuestros comentarios y
hablamos debate por supuesto si este
vídeo se ha resultado interesante no
olvidéis darle a like y suscribiros al
politik si es que aún no lo habéis hecho
una vez más Muchas gracias por estar ahí
un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]